[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight today was a big winner
seem to be for Republicans in the
Congress Democrats came to their demands
the government is back open at Henry
we'll have details on that in just a
minute
also there are new text messages tonight
from the FBI with stunning revelations
about the Hillary Clinton investigation
even if you think you know a lot about
it
stay tuned pretty remarkable but first
for more than a year on this show we've
discussed our country's immigration
policies pretty much every night we've
asked supporters of open borders how can
you justify this do American citizens
benefit from these policies or not we
still don't know
finally from MSNBC comes an answer on
her weekend show this Saturday anchor
joy Reed interviewed a genealogist who
had done historical research on my
family apparently one of my ancestors
came to this country in 1860 from
Switzerland I didn't even know that
until read show aired because I have
zero interest in the subject that was
more than a hundred and fifty years ago
it is irrelevant to the decisions that I
make as a father or a citizen or an
employee of Fox News it tells us
precisely nothing about our modern
immigration policy America's economy has
changed quite a bit since the Civil War
yet according to MSNBC this fact is a
conversation ender a single 19th century
Swiss relative means you are now
required to support green cards for
everyone who jumps the borders or
overstays a visa in 2018 boom
tastes closed as Reid's guests put it
people in genealogical glass houses
shouldn't throw stones
meaning me well as is so often the case
it's hard to know exactly whether this
was meant as a legitimate point of
debate or whether it was part of an
elaborate parody Monty Python does dacha
but there's absolutely no doubt about
the sincerity of what came next here's
joy Reed's response she wasn't joking at
all
watch Tucker has been one of the most
aggressive at putting forward what a lot
of people have seen as a pretty
blatantly white actually list view of
what immigration should be like so joy
Reid is accusing us of racism let's
pause for a moment and savor the irony
that reads entire public career has been
built on race baiting try to watch her
show for 20 minutes and see for yourself
this is the woman who urged the
Democratic Party to give up on white
voters who voted for Obama and then
Trump saying their votes weren't worth
fighting for that was last August
in October she suggested that White
House chief of staff John Kelly was
somehow a bigot because he grew up
around Irish Catholics after House
Majority Whip Steve Scalise was shot and
nearly killed by a progressive activist
last summer Reid openly wondered if we
should hope for his recovery
watch it's a delicate thing because you
know obviously everybody is wishing the
congressman well and hoping that issue
but Steve Scalise has a history that
it's we've all been forced to sort of
ignore on race he did come to leadership
after some controversy over attending a
white nationalist event which he says he
didn't know what it was he also
co-sponsored a bill to amend the
Constitution to define marriage as
between a man and a woman because he is
in jeopardy and everyone is pulling for
him are we required in a moral sense to
put that aside at the moment so enjoy
Reid accuses you of harboring racist
thoughts trust me
it's projection but it's also a
political tactic Reid can't explain why
this country so badly needs two
important millions of additional poor
people nobody on the Left can explain
that because there's no real answer so
they attempt to short-circuit the
conversation with slurs that's a shame
immigration matters it determines who
lives in this country who chooses our
government who shapes our future it's
hard to think of a public policy topic
more central to everything we've tried
our best to discuss immigration
reasonably and with civility most of the
time we succeed not all but we try we
tried to make a rational case where we
think ought to be done
we'd like immigration policies that
favor the America middle class over
foreign countries corporate elites and
lobbyists we think that laws passed by
our Congress ought to be respected and
enforced not mocked and ignored by our
own leaders we believe that America is
an actual place not just an abstract
idea it's a distinct country with its
own history language tradition values
change when it comes want to be
thoughtful and incremental we owe that
to the people who already
live here people of all colors and
backgrounds we're suspicious of efforts
to remake our society wholesale
especially just so a small group of
taste makers can feel virtuous or have
cheaper nannies any change is hard
demographic change especially is hard
let's stop lying about that it always
hurts the weak and economically
vulnerable first someone ought to be
thinking about their interest too
those are our views and they're not
extreme and we know that because we've
seen the polling on the subject a huge
number of Americans agree with what we
just said if you don't believe it look
up the views of african-american voters
on illegal immigration they are not what
joy read to put it mildly they know what
the cost has been those are disagree
with any of this are always welcome here
this is the only show on television that
books guests every night who have a
different view we look hard for the
smartest and most articulate people we
can find you can listen to both sides on
this show and you can make up your own
mind the organized left hates that they
no longer believe in debate they believe
in power accumulating it and most of all
in wielding it anyone who gets in their
way
gets shouted down in this case as a
racist that doesn't work anymore
what was once a devastating attack on a
person's character is now just
background noise when everything is
racist from ice cream trucks to dr.
Seuss nothing is the term has been
devalued by reckless overuse and that's
a shame because it still applies there's
still plenty of racism in America maybe
more now possibly than in generations
Americans are attacked openly for the
race every day in print on television at
public gatherings people are punished
for their race in hiring and college
admissions in government and private
contracting the left supports all of
this it's central to their worldview
it's key to their political strategy but
it's totally wrong and we plan to keep
saying that we still believe in what
used to be the central premise of
American liberalism people ought to be
judged on what they do not on how they
look or who their parents were or what
their ancestors did we don't believe in
collective punishment or reward we
believe in the individual and because we
do we think our immigration policy ought
to be driven by what each individual can
add to America nobody has the right to
be admitted by lottery or because they
happen to be related to someone who's
already here
or because they stuck in and is too
politically difficult to make them leave
that's what we think disagree with it
you are always welcome on this show
[Music]